so the Hebrews created history as we
know it
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
and we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest ethical Spirit to
which we're beholden is presented
precisely as that spirit that allies
itself with the cause of Freedom against
tyranny I want villains to get punished
but do you want the villains to learn
before they have to pay the ultimate
price that's such a Christian question
that has to do with attention by the way
it has to do with with a subsidiary
hierarchy like a hierarchy of attention
which is set up in a in in a way in
which all the levels can have room to
exist let's say and so you know these
new the new systems the new way let's
say the new Urban urbanist movement
similar to what you're talking about
that's what they've understood it's like
we need places of intimacy in terms of
the house we need places of communion in
terms of you know parks and Alleyways
and and buildings where we meet and a
church all these places that kind of
manifest our community together yeah so
so those existed coherently for long
periods of time and then the abundance
post World War II and some ideas about
like what what life could be like cause
this big change and that change
satisfied some needs people got houses
but broke community Community needs and
then new sets of ideas about what's the
synthesis what's the possibility of
having your own home but also having
Community not having to drive 15 minutes
for every single thing and some people
live in those worlds and some people
don't do you think we'll be smart so one
of the problems why were we smart enough
to solve some of those because we had 20
years but now because one of the things
that's happening now is we're as you
pointed out earlier is we're going to be
producing equally revolutionary
Transformations but at a much smaller
scale of time what's natural to our
children is so different than was
natural to us but what was natural to us
was very different from our parents so
some some changes get upset excepted
generationally really so what's made you
so optimistic
[Music]
hello everyone
watching on YouTube or listening on
Associated platforms I'm very excited
today to bring to be bringing you two of
the people I admire most intellectually
I would say and morally for that matter
Jonathan pajo and uh Jim Keller very
different thinkers Jonathan pajo is a
French Canadian liturgical artist and
icon Carver known for his work featured
in museums across the world he carves
Eastern Orthodox among other traditional
images and teaches an online carving
class he also runs a YouTube channel
this symbolic World dedicated to the
exploration of symbolism across history
and religion Jonathan is one of the
deepest religious thinkers I've ever met
Jim Keller
is a microprocessor engineer known very
well in the relevant communities and
Beyond them for his work at Apple and
AMD among other corporations he served
in the role of architect for numerous
game-changing processors has co-authored
multiple instruction sets for highly
complicated designs
and is credited for being the key player
behind amd's renewed ability to compete
with Intel in the high-end CPU Market
in 2016 Keller joined Tesla
becoming vice president of autopilot
Hardware Engineering in 2018 he became a
senior vice president for Intel
in 2020 he resigned due to disagreements
over Outsourcing production but quickly
found a new position at tens torrent as
Chief technical officer we're going to
sit today and discuss the perils and
promise of artificial intelligence and
it's a conversation I'm very much
looking forward to so welcome to all of
you watching and listening I thought it
would be interesting to have a three-way
conversation
um Jonathan and I have been talking a
lot lately especially with John viveki
and some other people as well about the
fact that we seem
it seems necessary for us to view for
human beings to view the world through a
story in fact that
are
when we describe the structure that
governs our action and our perception
that is a story and so we've been trying
to puzzle out I would say to some degree
on the religious front
what might be the deepest stories and
I'm very curious about the fact that we
perceive the world through a story human
beings do and that seems to be a
fundamental part of our cognitive
architecture and of cognitive
architecture in general According to
some of the world's top neuroscientists
and I'm curious and I know Jim is
interested in cognitive processing and
in Building Systems that in some sense
seem to run in a manner analogous to the
manner in which our brains run and so
I'm curious about the overlap between
the notion that we have to view the
world through a story and what's
happening on the AI front there's all
sorts of other places that we can take
the conversation so maybe I'll start
with you Jim do you want to tell people
what you've been working on and maybe
give a bit of a background to everyone
about how to how you conceptualize
artificial intelligence
yeah sure so first I'll say technically
I'm not
an artificial intelligent researcher I'm
a computer architect
and I'd say my skill set goes from you
know somewhere around the atom up to the
program so we uh we make transistors at
atoms we make logical Gates out of
transistors we make computers out of
logical Gates we run programs on those
and recently we've been able to run
programs fast enough
to do something called a artificial
intelligence model or neural network
depending on how we say it
um
and then we're building chips now
that run artificial intelligence models
fast and we have a novel way to do it a
company I work at but lots of people are
working on it and
I think
we were sort of taken by surprise what's
happened in the last five years how
quickly
models started to do interesting and
intelligent seeming things
um
there's been an estimate that human
brains do about 10 to the 18th
operations a second which sounds like a
lot it's a billion billion operations a
second and a little computer you know
the processor in your phone probably
does 10 billion operations a second
you know ish and then if you use the GPU
maybe 100 billion something like that
and
big modern AI computers like open AI use
this or Google or somebody
they're doing like 10 to the 16th maybe
maybe slightly more operations a second
so they're within a factor of a hundred
of a human brain's raw computational
ability and by the way that could be
completely wrong our understanding of
how the human brain does computation
could be wrong but lots of people have
estimated based on number of neurons
number of connections how fast neurons
fire how many operations a neuron firing
seems to involve
I mean the estimates range by a couple
orders of magnitude but
when our computers got fast enough
we started to build things called
language models and image models that do
fairly remarkable things
so what have you seen in the last few
years that's been indicative of this of
the change that you described as
revolutionary what what are the com what
are computers doing now that you that
you found surprising because of this
increase in speed yeah you can have a
language model read a 200 000 word book
and summarize it fairly accurately
so it can extract out the gist the gist
of it can it do that with fiction yeah
yeah and I'm going to introduce you to a
friend who took a language model and
changed it
and fine-tuned it with Shakespeare
and use it the right screen place
that are pretty good
and and these kinds of things are really
interesting and then
we were talking about this a little bit
earlier so when computers do
computations
you know a program will say add a equal
B plus c
the computer does those operations on
representations of information ones and
zeros it doesn't understand them at all
the computer has no understanding of it
but what we call a language model
translates information like words and
images and ideas
into a space where the program the ideas
and the operation it does on them are
all essentially the same thing
we'll be right back with Jonathan pajoto
and Jim Keller first we wanted to give
you a sneak peek at Jordan's new
documentary logos and literacy
I was very much struck by how the
translation of the biblical writings
jump started the development of literacy
across the entire world illiteracy was
the norm the pastor's home was the first
school and every morning it would begin
with singing the Christian faith is a
singing religion probably 80 percent of
scripture memorization today exists only
because of what is sung this is amazing
here we have a Gutenberg Bible Bible
printed on the Press of Johann gubern
science and religion are opposing forces
in the world but historically that has
not been the case now the book is
available to everyone from Shakespeare
to modern education and medicine and
science to to civilization itself it is
the most influential book in all history
and hopefully people can walk away with
at least a sense of that
right so a language model can produce
words and then use those words as inputs
and
it seems to have an understanding of
what those words are so which is very
different from our computer I'm curious
operates on data about the language
models I mean my sense of at least in
part how we understand the story
is that
maybe we're watching a movie let's say
and we get some sense of the characters
goals
and then we see the manner in which that
character perceives the world and we in
some sense adopt his goals which is to
identify with character and then we play
out a panoply of emotions and
motivations on our body because we now
inhabit that goal space and we
understand the character as a
consequence of mimicking the character
with our own physiology
and you you have computers that can
summarize the gist of a story but they
don't have that underlying physiology
first of all that's it's a theory that
your physiology has anything to do with
it you could
understand the character's goals and
then get involved in the details of the
story and then you're predicting the
path of the story
and also having expectations and hopes
for this story yeah and a good story
kind of takes you on a ride because it
teases you with
doing some of the things you expect but
also doing things that are unexpected
and possibly that creates emotional that
could yeah it does it does so in an AI
model
so you can easily have a set of goals so
you have your personal goals and then
when you watch the story you have those
goals yeah you put those together
like how many goals is that like the
stories goals in your goals hundreds
thousands those are small numbers right
then you have the story
the a model can predict the story too
just as well as you can howdy and that's
the thing that I find mysterious is that
as the story progresses it can look at
the error between
what it predicted and what actually
happened
and then iterate on that right so you
would call that emotional excitement
disappointment anxiety anxiety yeah
definitely well a big part of what
anxious
discrepancy in fact some of those states
are manifesting your body because you
trigger hormone Cascadia a bunch of
stuff but you also can just scan your
brain and see that stuff move around
right right
and
you know the AI model can have an error
function and look at the difference
between what it expected and not and you
could call that the emotional state yeah
yeah well if you want it I just talked
with it but not speculation but no no I
think that's actually but uh you know we
can make an AI model that could predict
a result of a story probably better than
the average person
so one of some people are really good at
you know they're rarely well educated
about stories or they know the genre or
something but yeah but you know these
things and what they see today is the
capacity of the models is if you say
start describing a lot it'll make sense
for a while but it'll slowly stop making
sense
but that that's possible that's simply
the capacity of the model right now and
the the model is not well not grounded
enough in the settle to say goals in
reality or something to make sure so
what do you think would happen Jonathan
this is this is I think associated with
the kind of things that we've talked
through to some degree so one of
my hypotheses let's say about
deep stories is that they're they're
they're
metagists in some sense so you could
imagine a hundred people telling you a
tragic story and then you could
reduce each of those tragic stories to
the gist of the tragic story and then
you could aggregate the gists and then
you'd have something like a meta tragedy
and I would say the deeper the gist the
more religious light the story gets and
that's part of it's that idea is part of
the reason that I wanted to bring you
guys together I mean one of the things
that what you just said makes me wonder
is imagine that you took Shakespeare
and you took Dante and you took like the
the canonical Western writers and you
trained an AI system to ex to understand
the structure of each of them and then
and now you have you can pull out the
summaries of those
structures the gists and then couldn't
you pull out another gist out of that so
it would be like the essential element
of Dante and Shakespeare and I want to
hear what John is
so so there's here's here's one funny
thing to think about you use the word
pull out so when you train a model to
know something
you can't just look in it and say what
is it no you have to Quirk it
right right what's the next sentence in
this paragraph what's the answer to this
question there's a thing on the internet
now now called prompt engineering and
it's the same way I I can't look in your
brain to see what you think yeah I have
to ask you what you think because if I
killed you and scanned your brain and
got the got the current state of all the
synapses and stuff hey you'd be dead
which should be sad and B I wouldn't
know anything about your thoughts your
thoughts are embedded in this model that
your brain carries around
and you can express it in a lot of ways
and so that so you could uh how do you
train so this is my my big question is I
mean because the way that I've been
seeing it until now is that that
artificial intelligence is it it's based
on us it's not it doesn't exist
independently from humans and it doesn't
have care the question would be why does
the computer care yeah that's that's
that's not true well what is a computer
care to get the gist of the story
well yeah so I think you're asking kind
of the wrong question so so you can
train an AI model on like the physics
and reality and images in the world just
with images
and there are people who are figuring
out how to train a model with just
images but the the model itself still
conceptualizes things like tree and dog
and action and run because those all
exist in the in the world
right so
and you can actually train so and when
you train a model with all the language
and words so all information has
structure
and I know you're a structure guy from
your video so if you look around you at
any image every single point you see
makes sense yeah
right it's an Italian it's a
teleological structure it's like a it's
a purpose in Laden structure right so
this is something so it turns out all
the words that have ever been spoken by
human beings also have structure right
right and and so physics has structure
and then it turns out that some of the
deep structure of images and actions and
words and sentences are related
like there's actually a common core of
like you imagine there's like a
knowledge space
and and sure there's details of humanity
where you know they prefer this this
accent versus that those are kind of
details but they're coherent in the
language model but the language models
themselves are coherent with our world
ideas
and humans are trained in the world just
the way the models are trained in the
world they look a little baby
as it's learning looking around it's
training on everything it sees when it's
very young and then his training rate
goes down and it starts interacting when
it's with what it's learning interacting
with the people around but it's trying
to survive it's it's trying to live it
has like it has a the the infant or the
child has kids aren't trying the the
weights and the neurons aren't trying to
live what they're trying to do is reduce
the error so neural networks generally
are predictive things like what's coming
next
what makes sense you know how does this
work
and when you train them when you train
an AI model
you're training it to reduce the error
in the model
and if you're modeling okay let me ask
you about that so well first of all and
so babies are doing the same thing like
they're looking at stuff go around and
in the beginning their neurons are just
randomly firing but as it starts to get
object permanent it's a look at stuff it
starts predicting what will make sense
for that thing to do and when it doesn't
make sense it'll it'll it'll update as
well basically it Compares its
prediction to the events and then it
will adjust its its prediction so in a
in a story prediction model the AI would
predict the story then compare it to its
prediction and then fine tune itself
slowly as it trains itself okay reverse
you could ask it to say given the set of
things tell the rest of the story and it
could do that
right and that's what and and the state
of it right now is there are people
having conversations with this that are
pretty good so I talked to Carl friston
about this prediction idea in some
detail and so first and for those of you
who are watching and listening is one of
the world's top neuroscientists and he's
developed an entropy
enclosure model of conceptualization
which is analogous to one that I was
working on uh I suppose a proc across
approximately the same time frame so
the first issue and this has been well
established in the neuropsychological
literature for quite a long time is that
anxiety is an indicator of discrepancy
between prediction and actuality
and then positive emotion also looks
like a discrepancy reduction indicator
so imagine that you're moving towards a
goal and then you you evaluate what
happens as you move towards the goal and
if you're moving in the right direction
what happens is what you might say what
you'll expect to happen and that
produces positive emotion and it's
actually an indicator of reduction in
entropy
that's that's one way of looking at
looking at it then the point is yeah
yeah you have a bunch of words in there
that are psychological definitions of
States but you could say there's a
prediction in Earth a prediction yes
you're reducing error yes but but what's
it what's simple but what I'm trying to
make a case for is that your emotions
directly map that both positive and
negative emotion look like they're
signifiers of discrepancy reduction well
on the positive and negative emotion
side but then there's a complexity that
that I think is germane to part of
Jonathan's query which is that
so the neuropsychologists and the
cognitive scientists have talked a lot a
long time about expectation prediction
and discrepancy reduction but one of the
things they haven't talked about is it
isn't exactly that you expect things
it's that you desire them you want them
to happen like because you could imagine
that there's a there's in some sense a
literally infinite number of things you
could expect and we we don't strive only
to match prediction we strive to bring
about what it is that we want and so we
have these preset systems that are
teleological that are motivational
systems well I mean it depends like if
you're sitting idly on the beach
like and a bird flies by you expect it
to fly along in a regular path right but
you don't really want that to happen
yeah but you don't want it to turn into
something that could Peck out your eyes
either like there's a disaster yeah but
but you're you're kind of following it
with your expectation to look for
discrepancy yes now you'll also have a
you know depends on the person somewhere
between 10 and a million desires right
and and then you also have fears and
avoidance and those are contexts so if
you're sitting on the beach with some
anxiety that the birds are going to
swerve at you and knock your eyes out
yeah so then you might be watching it
much more attentively than somebody who
doesn't have that worry for example well
but both of you can predict where it's
going to fly and you will both notice a
discrepancy right the motivations one
way of conceptualizing fundamental
motivation is they're like don't they're
like a primary prediction domains right
and so it helps us narrow our
attentional Focus because I know I know
when you're when you're sitting and and
and you're not motivated in any sense
you can be doing just in some sense
trivial expectation computations but
often we're in a highly motivated State
sure and what we're expecting is bounded
by what we desire and what we desire is
oriented as Jonathan pointed out towards
the fact that we want to exist and one
of the things I don't understand and
wanted to talk about today is how the
how the computer models the i o models
can generate intelligible sense without
this without mimicking that sense of
motivation because you've said for
example they can just derive the
patterns from observations of the
objective world but there's a so let's
so again
I don't want to do all the talking but
so so AI generally speaking like when I
first learned about it had two two
behaviors they call it inference in
training so inferences you have a
trained model so you say you give it a
picture and say is there a cat in it and
it tells you where the cat is that's
inference the model has been trained to
know where a cat is and training is the
process of giving it an input an
expected output and when you first start
training the model gives you garbage out
like an untrained brain but and then you
you take the difference between the
garbage output and the expected output
and call that the error and then they
invent the big Revelation was something
called back propagation with gradient
descent but that means takes the error
and divide it up across the layers and
correct those calculations so that when
you put a new thing in it gives you a
better answer
and then to somewhat my astonishment if
you have a model of sufficient capacity
and you train it with a hundred million
images if you give it a novel image and
say tell me where the cat is it can do
it
right that's called in that's called so
training is the process of doing a pass
with an expected output and propagating
an error back through the network and
inferences to the behavior of putting
this something in and getting it out
there yeah I think am I like I'm really
pulling but there's there's a third
piece which is what the new models do
which is called generative it's called a
generative model
so for example say you put in a sentence
and you say predict the next word this
is the simplest thing so it predicts the
next word so you add that word to the
input
and I'll say predict the next word so it
contains the original sentence and the
word you generated and it keeps
generating words that make sense in the
context of the original word in addition
right right this is the simplest basis
and then it turns out you can train this
to do lots of things you can change it
to summarize a sentence you can train it
to answer a question there's a big thing
about you know like Google every day has
hundreds of millions of people asking it
questions giving answers and then rating
the results you can train a model with
that information so you can ask it a
question it gives you a sensible answer
but I I think in what you said I
actually have the the issue that has
been
going through my mind so much is when
you said you know people put in the
question and then they rate the answer
my intuition is that the intelligence
still comes from humans in the sense
that
it seems like in order to train whatever
AI you have to be able to give it a lot
of power and then say at the beginning
this is good this is bad this is good
this is bad like reject certain things
accept certain things in order to then
reach a point when then you train the AI
and so that that's what I mean about the
care so the care will will come from
humans because the care is the one
giving it the value saying this is the
this is what is valuable this is what is
not valuable in your calculation
so so when they first so there's the
program called alphago I learned how to
play go better than a human so there's
two ways to train the model one is they
have a huge database of lots of Go Games
with good winning moves so they trained
the model with that and that worked
pretty good
and they also took
two simulations of go and they did
random moves
and alls that happened was these two
simulators played one go game and they
just recorded whichever moves happened
to win
and it started out really horrible
and I just started training the model
this is called adversarial learning it's
a particular adversarial it's like you
know you make your moves randomly
and you train a model and so they train
multiple models and over time those
models got very good and they actually
got better than human players
because the humans have limitations
about what they know whereas the models
could experiment in a really random
space and and go very far yeah but
experiment towards the brothers watching
the game
yes well but you can experiment towards
all kinds of things it turns out
and and humans are also training that
way like when you were learning you were
reading you were said this is a good
book this is a bad book this is good
sentence construction it's good spelling
so you've gotten so many error signals
over your life well that's what culture
does in large Partners culture does that
religion does that your everyday
experience does that your family so we
embody that yeah right and we're all and
everything that happens to us we process
it on the inference pass which generates
outputs and then sometimes we look at
that and say hey that's unexpected or
that got a bad result or that got bad
feedback and then we we back propagate
that and update our models
so could could very well trained models
can then train other models so the the
difference right now are the smartest
people in the world so the biggest
question the biggest question that I
that that comes now based on what you
said is
because my my main point is to try to
show how it seems like artificial
intelligence is always an extension of
human intelligence like it remains an
extension of human intelligence and
maybe the way down can't be true at all
so do you think that do you think that
at some point the artificial
intelligence will be able to because the
goals recognizing cats you know uh
writing plays all these goals our goals
which are which are based on embodied
human existence could you train what
could an AI at some point develop a goal
which would be uncomprehensible to
humans because of its its own existence
yeah I mean like for example there's a
small population of humans that enjoy
math right and they are pursuing
you know adventures in math space that
are incomprehensible to 99.99 of humans
but that's but they're interested in it
and you can imagine like an AI program
working with those mathematicians and
coming up with very novel math ideas
and then interacting with them but they
could also
you know if some AIS were were
elaborating out really interesting and
detailed stories they could come up with
stories that are really interesting
we're going to see it pretty soon like
could there be it at everything a story
that is interesting only to the AI and
not interesting to us that's possible
So Stories are like I think some high
level information space so so the the
the Computing age of Big Data there's
all this data running on computers where
nobody the only humans understood it
right the computers don't so AI programs
are now at the state where
the information the processing and the
feedback loops are all kind of in the
same space
they're still you know relatively
rudimentary to humans like in some AI
programs and certain things are better
than humans already but for the most
part they're not
but it's moving really fast so and so
you could imagine
you know I think in five or ten years
most people's best friends will be AIS
and you know they'll know you really
well and they'll be interested in you
and you know it's kind of like your real
friends
yeah real friends are problematic
they're only interested in you when
you're interested yeah yeah real friends
are the AI systems will love you even
when you're dull and miserable well
there's there's and there's so much idea
space to explore
and humans have a wide range some humans
like to go through their everyday life
doing their everyday things and some
people spend a lot of time like you a
lot of time reading and thinking and
talking and arguing and debating
you know and
you know that's there's going to be like
say A diversity of possibilities with
what's what
a thinking thing can do when the
thinking is fairly Unlimited
so I'm curious about I'm still I'm
curious in pursuing this this issue that
Jonathan uh has been developing so
there's a there's a literally infinite
number of ways virtually infinite number
of ways that we could take images of
this room right now if a human being is
taking images of this room they're going
to be they're going to sample a very
small space of that infinite range of
possibilities because if I was taking
pictures in this room in all likelihood
I would take pictures of ident objects
that are identifiable to human beings
that are functional to human beings at a
level of focus that makes those objects
clear and so then you could imagine that
the set of all images on the internet
has that implicit structure of
perception built into it and that's a
function of what human beings find
useful you know I mean I could take a
photo of you that was the focal depth
was here and here and here and here and
here and two inches past you and now I
suppose you because it's a technology
for that called light fields okay so so
then you could if you had that picture
properly done then you could move around
in an image and and see but yeah fair
enough I get your point like the the
human recorded data has here's her
biology built into it has our biology
built into it but also unbelievably
detailed encoding of how physical
reality works
right so every single Pixel in those
pictures even though you kind of
selected the view the focus the frame
right
it still encoded a lot more information
than you're processing
right and if you take a large it turns
out if you take a large number of images
of things in general so you've seen
these things where you take a 2D image
and turn it into a 3D image yeah right
the reason that works is even in the 2D
image the 3DS
in the room actually got embedded in
that yeah then if you have the right
understanding of how physics and reality
works you can reconstruct a 3D model
you know an AI scientist may cruise
around the world with infrared and radio
wave cameras and they might take
pictures of all different kinds of
things and every once in a while they'd
show up and go hey the sun you know I've
been staring at the sun and the
ultraviolet and radio yes for the last
month and it's way different than
anybody's thought because humans tend to
look at light and visible spectrum
and you know it there could be some
really novel things coming out of that
well so so but humans also we live in
the Spectrum we live in because it's a
pretty good one for planet Earth like it
wouldn't be obvious that AI would start
some different place like visible
spectrum is is interesting for a whole
bunch of reasons right so in a set of
images that are human derived you're
saying that there's the way I would
conceptualize that is that there's two
kinds of logos embedded in that one
would be that you could extract out from
that set of images what was relevant to
human beings but you're saying that the
fine structure of the objective World
outside of human concern is also
embedded in the set of images and that
an AI system could extract out a
representation of the world but also a
representation of what's motivating to
human beings yes so and then some human
scientists already do look at the sun in
radio waves and other things because
they're trying to you know get different
angles on how things work
yeah well I guess it so it's a it's a
curious thing it's like the same with
like buildings and architecture mostly
fit people
well the the other you know there's a
reason for that the reason why I keep
coming back hammering the same point is
that even in terms of the development of
the AI that is developing AI requires
immense amount of money energy
uh you know and time and so that's a
transient thing in 30 years it won't
cost anything so it's that's that's
going to change so fast it's amazing so
that's that's a like super computers
used to cost millions of dollars and now
your phone is the super computer so it's
the time between millions of dollars and
ten dollars is about 30 years
so it's like I'm I'm just saying it's
like the time and effort isn't a thing
in in technology it's moving pretty fast
it's just that's just it just says the
date yeah but even making even making
let's say even
I mean I guess maybe the this is the
nightmare question like could you
imagine an AI system which becomes
completely autonomous which is creating
itself even physically through automized
uh factories which is you know
programming itself which is creating its
own goals which is not at all connected
to human endeavor
yeah I mean individual researchers can
you know I have a friend who I'm going
to introduce you to him tomorrow he
wrote a program that scraped all of the
internet and trained an AI model to be
uh a language model on a relatively
small computer and in 10 years
the computer he could easily afford
would be as smart as a human so he could
train that pretty easily
and that model could go on Amazon and
buy a hundred more of those computers
and copy itself
so yeah we're we're 10 years away from
that
and then but then why like why would it
do that I mean what does it does is it
possible it's all about the motivational
question I think that that's what what
even Jordan and I both have been coming
at from the outset is like so you have
an image right you have an image of of
Skynet or of the Matrix you know in
which the sentient AI is actually
fighting for its survival so it has a
survival Instinct which is pushing it I
was thinking of to self-perpetuate like
to to to to to replicate itself and to
create variation on itself in order to
survive and identify as humans as an
obstacle to that you know
yeah yeah so you have a whole bunch of
implicit assumptions there so so humans
last I checked are unbelievably
competitive and when you let people get
into Power with no checks on them they
typically run amok it's been history
historical experience and then humans
are
you know self-regulating to some extent
obviously with some serious outliers
because they self-regulate with each
other and humans and AI models at some
point will have to find their own
calculation of self-regulation and
and trade-offs about that yeah because
AI doesn't feel pain at least as we if
that we don't know that it feels well
lots of humans don't feel pain either so
I mean that's I mean humans feeling pain
or not didn't you know it doesn't stop a
whole bunch of activity I mean that's I
mean it doesn't the fact that we feel
pain doesn't stop doesn't regulate many
people right right I mean there's
definitely people like you know children
if you threaten them with you know go to
your room and stuff you can regulate
them that way but some kids ignore that
completely and adults and it's often
counterproductive yeah so so right you
know you know
culture and societies and organizations
we regulate each other you know
sometimes in competition and cooperation
yeah do you do you think that we've
talked about this to some degree for
decades I mean when you look at how fast
things are moving now and as you push
that along
what and what when you look out 10 years
and you see the relationship between the
AI systems that are being built and
human beings what do you envision
or can you envision it
okay well can I yeah so like I said I'm
a computer guy
and I'm watching this with let's say
some Fascination as well
I mean the last so Ray cartswell said
you know prior progress accelerates yeah
right so we we have this idea that 20
years of progress is 20 years but you
know the last 20 years of progress was
20 years in the next 20 years would
probably be you know five to ten right
right right and and you can really feel
that happening to some level that causes
social stress independent of whether
it's AI or or Amazon deliveries you know
what you know there's so many things
that are going into the the stress of it
all but there's but there's progress
which is an extension of human capacity
and then there's this progress which I'm
hearing about the way that you're
describing it which seems to be an
inevitable progress towards creating
something which is more powerful than
you
right and so what is that I don't even
understand that drive like what is that
drive to to create something which can
supplant you so look at the average
person in the world right so the average
person already exists in this world
because the average person is halfway up
the human hierarchy there's already many
people more powerful than any of us
there they could be smarter they could
be richer they could be better connected
we already live in a world like very few
people are at the top of anything
right so that's already a thing so
basically the drive to make someone a
superstar let's say or the drive to
elevate someone above you that would be
the same drive that is bringing us to
creating these Ultra powerful machines
because we have that like we have a
drive to elevate like you know when we
see a rock star that we like people want
to submit themselves to that they want
to dress like them they want to raise
them up above them as an example
something to follow right something to
say to to subject themselves to you see
that with leaders you see that in the
political world ah
and in teams you see that in sports
teams the same thing and so do you think
well we've always tried to build things
that are Beyond us you know I mean I
mean I mean it's about are we building
are we building a God is that the is
that what people is that the drive that
is pushing someone towards because when
I hear what you're describing uh Jim I
hear something that is extremely
dangerous right sounds extremely
dangerous to the very existence of
humans yet I see humans acting and
moving in that direction almost without
being able to stop it as if there's no
one now I think it is Unstoppable that
well that's one of the things we've also
talked about is because I I've asked Jim
straight out you know
because of the hypothetical danger
associated with this why not stop doing
it and well part of his answer is the
ambivalence about the outcome but also
that it isn't obvious at all that in
some sense it's stoppable
I mean it's a it's the cumulative action
of many many people that are driving us
along and even if you took out one
player even a key player the probability
that you do anything but slowing
infinitesimally is is quite happy
because there's also a massive payoff
for those that will succeed it's also
set up that way people know that at
least
at least until the AI take over whatever
that whoever is on the line towards
increasing the power of the AI will will
rake in major Rewards
right well so there's a cognitive
acceleration right yeah I I can
recommend uh Ian Banks
as an author English author I think he
wrote a series of books on the he called
the culture novels and it was a world
where there was humans and then there
was AI is the smartest humans and AIS
that were dumber than humans but there
were some AIS that were much much
smarter and they they lived in harmony
because they mostly all pursued what
they wanted to pursue
humans pursued human goals and super
smart AIS pursue super smart AI goals
and and you know they they communicated
and worked with each other but but they
they mostly you know they're different
when they were different enough that
that was problematic their goals were
different enough that they didn't
overlap because one of the one of the
things that that would be my guess is
like these ideas were these super AIS
get smart and the first thing they do is
stomp out to humans it's like you don't
do that like you like you don't wake up
in the morning and think I have to stomp
out all the cats no the cats do cat
things and the Ants do ant things and
the birds do bird things and and super
smart mathematicians do smart
mathematician things and you know guys
who like to build houses do build house
things and you know everybody you know
the the world there's so much space in
the intellectual Zone
that
people people tend to go pursue the in a
good Society like you tend to pursue the
stuff that you do and then the people in
your Zone you self-regulate and you also
even in the social strategies we
self-regulate we I mean the the recent
political events of the last 10 years
the the weird thing to me has been
why of you know people with power been
overreaching to take too much from
people with less like that's bad
regulation but one of the things
go ahead of the aspects of increase in
power is that increase in power is
always mediated at least in one aspect
by the military by military by by let's
say physical power on others you know
and we can see that technology is linked
and has been linked always to military
power and so the idea that there could
be some ai's that will be our friends or
whatever is maybe possible but the idea
that there will be some AIS which will
be weaponized is seems absolutely
inevitable because increase in power is
always to increase in technological
power always moves towards towards
military so we've lived with atomic
bombs since the 40s
right so the
I mean the the solution to this has been
mostly
you know some form of mutual assured
destruction or
attacking me like the response to
attacking me is so much worse than the
yeah but it's also because we rest we
have reciprocity we recognize each other
as the same so if I look into the face
of another human there there's a limit
of how a different I think that person
is for me but if I'm hearing something
described as the possibility of super
intelligences that have their own goals
their own cares their own structures
then how much mirror is there between
these two groups of people these two
groups well is there objection seems to
be something like
we're we're making we may be making when
we're doomsaying let's say and I'm not
saying there's no place for that we're
making the presumption of something like
a zero-sum competitive landscape right
is that the the idea and the idea behind
movies like like the Terminator is that
there is only so much resources and the
machines and the human beings would have
to fight over it and you can see that
that that could easily be a Preposterous
assumption now I I think that one of the
fundamental points you're making though
is also
um
there will definitely be people that
will weaponize Ai and those weaponized
AI systems will have as their goals
something like the destruction of human
beings at least under some circumstances
and then there's the possibility that
that will get out of control because the
most effective systems out destroying
human beings might be the ones that win
let's say and that that could happen
independently of whether or not it is a
true zero-sum competition yeah and also
the
the the effectiveness of military stuff
doesn't need very smart AI to be a lot
better than it is today
you know he's used to you know that like
the Star Wars movies where like you know
tens of thousands of years in the future
super highly trained you know Fighters
can't hit somebody running across the
field like that's silly right you can
already make a gun deck and hit
everybody in the room without aiming at
it it's you know there's like the
the military threshold is much lower
than any
intelligence threshold
like for danger and you know like to the
extent that we self-regulated through
the nuclear crisis it's interesting
um I don't know if it's because we
thought that the Russians were like us I
kind of suspect the problem was that we
thought they weren't like us and
but we still managed to make some
calculation to say that any kind of
attack would be mutually devastating
well when you when you look at you know
the destructive power of the military we
already have so far exceeds the planet
I'm I'm not sure like adding
intelligence to it is the Tipping Point
like like that's
and I think the more likely thing is
things that are truly Smart in different
ways will be interested in different
things
and then the possibility for let's say
Mutual flourishing is
is really interesting and I know artists
using AI already to do really amazing
things and and that's already happening
well when you when you're working on the
frontiers of AI development and you see
the development of increasingly
intelligent machines I mean I know that
part of what drives you is I don't want
to put words in your mouth but what
drives intelligent engineers in general
which is to take something that works
and make it better and maybe to make it
radically better and radically cheaper
so so there's this Tech drive toward
technological Improvement and I know
that you like to solve complex problems
and you do that extraordinarily well
what but do you do you is there also a
vision of
um a more abundant form of human
flourishing emerging from the from the
development so so what do you see
happening years ago it's like we're
going to run out of energy what's next
we're going to run out of matter right
like our ability to do what we want in
ways that are interesting and you know
for some people beautiful is limited by
a whole bunch of things because we're
you know partly it's technological and
partly what's you know we're stupidly
divisive
but um but there is there's possible
that there's also a reality which is one
of the things that technology has been
is of course an increase in power
towards desire towards human desire and
that is represented in mythological
stories where
let's say technology is used to
accomplish impossible desire right we
have you know the story of
the story of building the the mechanic
the bull around uh the king of Mino the
the wife of the king of Minos you know
in order to be inseminated by uh by a
bull we have the story The the we have
the story of the um
I swear Frankenstein Etc the story of
the Golem where we put our desire into
this increased power and then what
happens is that we don't know our
desires that's one of the things that
I've also been worried about in terms of
AI is that
we act we have secret desires that enter
into what we do that people aren't
totally aware of and as we increase
Empower these systems those desires
let's say the the like the idea for
example of the possibility of having an
AI friend and the idea that an AI friend
would be the best friend you've ever had
because that that friend would be the
nicest to you would care the most about
you would do all those things that would
be an exact example of what I'm talking
about which is it's really the story of
the genie right it's the story of the
the genie and the lamp where the genie
says what do you wish and the and the
person and I have unlimited power to
give it to you and so I give him my wish
but that wish has all these these
underlying implications that I don't
understand all these underlying
possibilities
the cool thing the more of almost all
those stories is having unlimited wishes
will be lead to your downfall and so
humans like if you give you know a young
person an unlimited amount of stuff to
drink for for six months they're going
to be falling down drunk and they're
going to get over it right having a
friend that's always your friend no
matter what it's probably going to get
boring pretty well the the literature on
marital stability indicates that so
there's a there's a sweet spot with
regards to marital stability in terms of
the ratio of negative to positive
communication
so if on average you receive five
positive Communications and one negative
communication from your spouse that's on
the low threshold for stability if it's
four positive to one negative you're
headed for divorce but interestingly
enough on the other end there's a
threshold as well which is that if it
exceeds 11 positive to one negative
you're also moving towards divorce
so there's so so so there might be
self-regulating mechanisms that would
incense take care of that you might find
a Yes Man AI friend
extraordinarily boring very very rapidly
but as opposed to an AI friend that was
interested in what you're interested in
it was actually interesting like you
know we go through friends in the course
of our lives like different friends are
interesting at different times and some
friends we grow with and that continues
to be really interesting for years and
years and other friends you know some
people get stuck in their thing and then
you've moved on or they've moved on or
something so
yeah I so we I tend to think of uh
like a world where there was more
abundance and more possibilities and
more
interesting things to do is is an
interesting okay okay so as modern
society has let the human population and
some people think this is a bad thing
but I don't know I I'm a fan of it you
know modern population has gone from
tens of to 100 million to billions of
people that's generally being a good
thing we're not running out of space
I've been in you know some of your
audience has probably been in an
airplane if you look out the window the
country is actually mostly empty
the oceans are mostly empty like we're
we're weirdly good at polluting large
areas but as soon as we decide not to we
don't have to like technology most most
of our you know energy pollution
problems are technical like we can stop
polluting like electric cars are great
so so here's so many things that we
could do technically
um I forget the guys name he said the
Earth could easily support a population
of petroleum people and trillion people
would be a lot more people doing you
know random stuff and he didn't imagine
that the future population would be a
trillion humans and a trillion AIS but
it probably will be
so we'll probably exist on multiple
planets which would be good the next
time an asteroid shows up so what do you
think about so so one of the things that
seems to be happening tell me if if you
think I'm wrong here and I think it's
germane to and Jordan I just want to
make the point you know where we are
compared to living in the Middle Ages
our lives are longer our our families
are healthier our children are more
likely to survive like many many good
things happens
like setting the clock back would be
good
you know if we have some care and people
who actually care about how culture
interacts with technology for the next
50 years
you know we'll get through this
hopefully more successful than we did
the atomic bomb and the Cold War
but it's it's okay so so it's a major
change I mean this is like like
your worries are you know I mean they're
they're relevant
but that you know but also you're
Jonathan your stories about how humans
have faced abundance and faced evil
Kings and evil overlords like we have
thousands of years of history of facing
the challenge of the future and the
challenge of things that cause radical
change yeah but it's just that that's
very valuable information you know
information but for the most part nobody
succeeded by stopping change they've
succeeded by
bringing to bear on the chains our
capability to self-regulate the balance
like a good life isn't having as much
gold as possible it's a boring life a
good life is you know having some
quality friends and doing what you want
and having some
some insight in life yeah and some
optimal Challenge and
you know and then in a world where a
larger percentage of people can have
Wealth live in relative abundance and
have tools and opportunities I think is
a good thing yeah and I don't I don't
want to pull back abundance but what I
have noticed is that that our abundance
brings a kind of nihilism to people and
I don't like I said I don't want to go
back I'm happy to live here and to have
these these Tech things but I but I
think it's something that I've also
noticed uh
that increase of of the capacity to
get your desires
when that increases to a certain extent
also leads to a kind of nihilism where
exactly that well yeah I wonder Jonah
said I wonder if that's part partly a
consequence
of the
erroneous maximization of short-term
desire I mean one of the things that you
might think about that could be
dangerous on the AI front is that we
optimize the manner in which we inter we
interact with our electronic gadgets to
capture short-term attention
right because there's a difference
between getting what you want right now
right now and getting what you need in
some more mature sense across a
reasonable span of time and one of the
things that does seem to be happening
online and I think it is driven by the
development of AI systems is that we're
we're assaulted by systems that
parasitize our short-term attention and
at the expense of longer term attention
and I if the AI systems emerge to
optimize attentional grip it isn't
obvious to me that they're going to
optimize for the attention that works
over the medium to long run right
they're gonna they're gonna be they
could conceivably maximize something
like whim centered
exactly because all the virality is
based on that all the the social media
yeah they're all based on this on this
reduction this reduction of attention
this reduction of desire to to reaching
your your rest let's say in that desire
right the like to click all these things
there yeah now yeah exactly so but but
that's something that you know so for
for reasons that are somewhat puzzling
but maybe not
you know the business models around a
lot of those interfaces are around
you know the part the users the product
and you know that the advertisers are
trying to get your attention yeah yeah
but that's something culture could
regulate We could decide that no we
don't we don't want Tech platforms to be
driven by advertising money like that
would be a smart decision probably
um and that could be a big change
and also if you see as an older see well
the problem is markets drive that in
some sense right and yeah and I know
they're driving that way we can take
steps like you know at various times you
know alcohol's been illegal like you you
can we Society can decide to regulate
all kinds of things
and you know sometimes some things need
to be regulated and some things don't
like when you buy a hammer you don't
fight with your hammer for its attention
right it Hammer's a tool you buy one
when you need one
nobody's marketing hammers to you like
like that that that has a relationship
that's transactional to your purpose
right yeah well our technology has
become a thing where
I mean but there's a relationship a lot
of things are so there's relationship
between human I would say High human
goals something like attention
and status
and what we talked about which is the
idea of elevating something higher in
order to see it as a model see these are
where intelligence exists in the human
person and so when we notice that in the
systems in the the platforms these are
the the these are the aspects of
intelligence which are being weaponized
in some ways
not against us but are just kind of
being weaponized because they're the
most beneficial at the short term to be
able to generate our constant attention
and so what I mean is that that is what
the as AIS are made of right they're
made of attention prioritization uh you
know good bad what what is it that that
is worth putting energy into in order to
predict towards a Telos and so yeah I'm
seeing so I'm seeing that it's the idea
that we could disconnect them suddenly
seems very difficult to me
yeah so I'll give it to to first I want
to give an old example so after after
World War II America went through this
amazing building boom of building
suburbs and the American dream was you
could have your own house your own yard
in the suburb with a good school right
so in the 50s 60s early 70s they were
building that like crazy by the time I
grew up I lived in this you know
Suburban dystopia right and we found
that that that as a goal wasn't a good
thing because people ended up in houses
separated from social social studies
instructors and then new towns are built
around like a hub with you know places
to go and eat you know so there was a a
good that was viewed in terms of
opportunity and abundance but it
actually was a fail culturally and then
some places it modified and continues in
some places are so dystopian you know
Suburban areas and some places people
simply learned to live
by the way it has to do with with a
subsidiary hierarchy like a hierarchy of
attention which is set up in a in in a
way in which all the levels can have
room to exist let's say and so you know
the these new the new systems the new
way let's say the new Urban urbanist
movement similar to what you're talking
about that's what they've understood
it's like we need places of intimacy in
terms of the house we need places of
communion in terms of you know parks and
Alleyways and and buildings where we
meet and a church all these places that
kind of manifest our community together
yeah so so those existed coherently for
long periods of time and then the
abundance post World War II and some
ideas about like what what life could be
like cause this big change and that
change satisfied some needs people cut
houses but broke Community needs and
then new sets of ideas about what what's
the synthesis what's the possibility of
having your own home but also having
Community not having to drive 15 minutes
for every single thing and some people
live in those worlds and some people
don't do you think we'll be smart so one
of the problems why were we smart enough
to solve some of those because we had 20
years but now because one of the things
that's happening now is we're as you
pointed out earlier is we're going to be
producing equally revolutionary
Transformations but at a much
smaller scale of time and so Mike one of
the things I wonder about I think it's
driving some of the concerns in the
conversation is
are we going to be
intelligent enough to
direct with regulation the
transformations of Technology as they
start to accelerate I mean we've already
look what's happened online I mean we've
inadvertently for example
radically magnified the voices of
narcissists Psychopaths and
machiavellians and we've done that so
intensely partly and I would say partly
as a conservation consequence of AI
mediation that I think it's it's
destabilizing the entire body it's a
stabilizing part of it like as Scott
Adams point out you just block everybody
that acts like that I don't pay
attention to people that talk like that
yeah but they seem they seem to be real
there's still places that are sensitive
to it like yeah 10 000 people here can
make a storm in some corporate you know
person you know fire somebody but I
think that's like we're five years from
that being over Corporation will go ten
thousand people out of 10 billion not a
big deal okay so you think yeah that's a
learning moment that will re-regulate
um
what's natural to our children is so
different than it was natural to us but
what was natural to us was very
different from our parents so some some
changes get upset excepted
generationally really so what's made you
so optimistic
what's means what do you mean optimistic
well most of the things that you have
said today and and maybe it's also
because we're pushing you I mean you you
really you know my my nephew Kyle is a
really smart clever guy he calls me a uh
what did he called it a cynical optimist
like I believe in people
like I like people but also people are
complicated they all got all kinds of
Nefarious goals like I worry a lot more
about people burning down the world than
I do about artificial intelligence just
because you know people
well you know people they're they're
difficult right and
and but the interesting thing is in
aggregate we mostly self-regulate and
when things change you have these
dislocations and then it's up to people
who talk and think and while we're
having this conversation I suppose to
talk about how how do we re-regulate
this stuff yeah well because one of the
things that one of the things that the
increase in power has done in terms of
AI and you can see it with Google and
you can see it online is that there are
certain people who hold the keys let's
say and and and then who hold the keys
to what you see and what you don't see
so you see that on Google right and you
know it if you know what searches to
make where you realize that this is not
this is actually being directed by
someone who now has huge amount of power
in order to direct my attention towards
their ideological purpose and so yeah
yeah so that's why like I think that to
me I personally think it would I always
tend to see AI as as an extension of
human power even though so there is this
idea that it could somehow become
totally independent I I still tend to
see it as an increase of the human care
and whoever will be able to hold the the
keys to that will have increase in power
and that can be like and I think we're
already seeing it well that's that's not
that's not really any different though
is it Jonathan the the situation that's
always confronted Us in the past I mean
we've always had to deal with the evil
Uncle of the king and we've always had
to deal with the fact that an increase
in ability could also produce a
commensurate increase in tyrannical
power
right I mean so that might be magnified
now and and maybe the danger in some
sense is more acute but possibly the
possibility is more present as well
because you get randomly to find hate
speech right you can train an AI to find
hate speech and then to act on that hate
speech immediately within now it's only
we're not only talking about social
media but we what we've seen is that
that is now
in being encroaching into payment
systems and into people losing their
bank account their access to different
services and so this idea of
automization you know there's an
Australian bank that already has decided
that it's a good thing to send all of
their customers a carbon load report
every month
right and to to offer them hints about
how they could reduce their their
polluting purchases let's say and well
at the moment that system is one of
voluntary compliance but you can
certainly see in a situation like the
one we're in now that the line between
voluntary compliance and involuntary
compulsion is very very thin
yeah so so I'd like to say so during the
early Computer World computers were very
big and expensive and then we they made
many computers and workstations but they
were still corporate only and then the
PC World came in all of a sudden PCS put
everybody online everybody could
suddenly see all kinds of stuff and you
know people could get a freedom
information act request put it online
somewhere and a hundred thousand people
could see it like it was an amazing
democratization moment and then there
was a similar but
a smaller Revolution with the world of
you know smartphones and apps but then
we've we've had a new completely
different set of companies by the way
you know from you know what happened in
the 60s 70s and 80s to today it's a very
different companies that control it and
and there are people who worry that AI
will be a winner take all thing now I
think so many people are using it and
they're working on so many different
places and the cost is going to come
down so fast that pretty soon you'll
have your own AI app that you'll use to
mediate the internet to strip out you
know the the endless stream of ads and
you can say well is this story objective
well here's the 15 stories and this has
been manipulated this way and this is
being manipulated that way and you can
say well I want what's what's more like
the real story
and the funny thing is
information that's broadly distributed
and has lots of inputs is very hard to
fake the whole thing
so right now a story can pull through a
major media outlet and if they can
control the narrative everybody gets the
fake story
but if the media is distributed across a
billion people who are all interacting
in some useful way
yeah there's real signal there and if
somebody stands up and says something
that's not true everybody go everybody
knows that's not true
so the like a good outcome with people
thinking seriously would be the
democratization of information and you
know objective facts in the same way the
same thing that happened with pecs
versus Corporate Central Computers could
happen again yeah
always creates the tooth at the same
time and so we saw that you know
increase in power creates creates first
or it depends in which direction happens
and it creates an increase in
decentralization increase in Access and
he creates it creates all that but then
it also at the same time creates the
counter reaction which is an increase in
control and increase in in
centralization and so
now the more the power is the more the
waves will the bigger the waves will be
and so the image of the image that 1984
presented to us you know of of people
going into newspapers and changing the
the the headlines and taking the
pictures out and doing that that now
obviously can happen with just a click
so you can click and you can change the
past you can change the past you can
change facts about the world because
they're all held you know online and
we've seen we've seen it happen
obviously in the media recently but it
so does decentralization win over
centralization how is that even possible
it seems I mean and it's also
interesting like when Amazon became a
platform
suddenly any mom and pop business could
have a you know Amazon eBay there's a
bunch of platforms which had an amazing
impact because any business could get to
anybody
but then the platform itself started to
control the information flow yeah right
but at some point that'll turn into
people go well why am I letting somebody
control my information flow when Amazon
objectively doesn't really have any
capability
right so so so like you point out though
the waves are getting bigger but they're
real waves it's the same with
information the information is all
online it's also on a billion hard
drives
right so somebody says I'm going to
erase objective fact the distributed
information system would say yeah go
ahead and erase it anywhere you want
here's another thousand copies of it
yeah and that's what so that's what but
again this is right to do today yeah
yeah and this is where thinking people
have to say yeah this is a serious
problem like if humans don't have
anything to fight for they get lazy and
you know
a little bit Dopey in my view like we do
have something to fight for and you know
that that's worse that's worth talking
about like what would what would a great
world with you know distributed you know
in human intelligence and artificial
intelligence working together in a
collaborative way to create abundance
and fairness and
you know like some some better way at
arriving at good decisions than what the
truth is that would be a good thing
but it you know it's not well we'll
leave it to the experts and then the
experts will tell us what to do that's a
bad thing yeah so that's
well so do you did the model that you
just laid out which which I think is
very I'm quite optimistic about that
yeah well it did happen on the
computational front I mean it was it
happened a couple times both directions
okay right you know the PC Revolution
was amazing yeah right and Microsoft was
a fantastic company it enabled everybody
to write a 10 50 program to use yeah
right and then at some point they're
also you know let's say a difficult
program company and they made money off
a lot of people and became extremely
valuable now for the most part they
haven't been that directional and
telling you what to do and think and how
to do it but they are a money-making
company
you know Apple created the app store
which is great but then they also take
30 of the App Store profits and there's
a whole section of the internet that's
fighting with apple about their control
of that platform right and in Europe you
know they've they've decided to regulate
some of that which that should be a
Converse that should be a social
cultural conversation about how should
that work yeah so so do you do you see
the more likely certainly the more
desirable future
is something like a set of distributed
AIS many of which are under personal in
personal relationship in some sense the
same way that we're in personal
relationship with our phones and our
computers and that that would give
people the industrations back so to
speak against this and there's lots of
people really interested in distributed
platforms
and one of the interesting thing about
the AI world is you know there's a
company called open Ai and they open
source a lot of it the AI research is
amazingly open it's all done in public
people publish the new models all the
time you can try them out people there's
a there's a lot of startups doing Ai and
all different kinds of places
you know it's it's it's it's a very
curious phenomena yeah and it's kind of
like a big huge Wave It's not like a you
you can't stop a wave with your hands
yeah what what do you think it's
happening waves there are two actually
in the Book of Revelation which is
describes the end or describes the
finality of all things or the totality
of all things is baby away for people
who are more secular to kind of
understand it and in that in that book
there are two images interesting images
about technology one is that there's a
dragon that falls from the heavens and
that Dragon makes a beast and then that
Beast makes an image of the Beast and
then the image speaks and when the image
speaks then people are so mesmerized by
the speaking image that they worship the
the Beast ultimately so that is one
image of let's say making and technology
in scripture in Revelation but there's a
lad another image which is the image of
the Heavenly Jerusalem and that image is
more an image of balance it's an image
of the city which comes down from heaven
with a garden in the center and then
becomes this glorious City and it says
the glory of all the kings is gathered
into the city like so the glory of all
the nations is gathered into this city
so now you see a technology which is at
the service of human flourishing and
takes the best of humans and brings it
into itself in order to kind of manifest
and it also has hierarchy which means it
has the natural at the center and then
has the artificial as serving the
natural you could say so those two
images seem to reflect these these two
waves that we see and this kind of idea
of a of a of an artificial intelligence
will be which will be ruling over us or
speaking over us but there's a there's a
secret person controlling it even in the
in Revelation it's like there's a
there's a beast controlling it and
making it speak so now we we we're
mesmerized by it and then this other
image so I don't I don't know Jordan if
you ever thought about those two images
in real relation is being related to
technology let's say
I I don't think I've thought about those
two image
image cry but I would say that the work
that I've been doing and I think the
work you've been doing too and the
public front reflects the dichotomy
between those images and it's relevant
to the points that Jim has been making I
mean we are definitely increasing our
technological power and you can imagine
that that'll increase our capacity for
tyranny and also our capacity for
abundance and then the question becomes
what do we need to do in order to
increase the probability that we tilt
the future towards Jerusalem and away
from the Beast and the reason that I've
been concentrating on helping people
bolster their individual morality to the
degree that I've managed that is because
I think that whether the outcome is the
positive outcome that in some sense Jim
is being outlining or the negative
outcomes that we've been querying him
about I think that's going to be
dependent on the individual ethical
choices of people well at the individual
level but then cumulatively right so if
we decide that we're going to worship
the image of the Beast so to speak
because we're mesmerized by our own
reflection that's another way of
thinking about it and we want to be the
victim of our own dark desires then the
Ia Revolution is going to go very very
badly but if if we decide that we're
going to aim up in some positive way and
we make the right micro decisions well
then maybe we can harness this
technology to produce a time of
abundance in the manner that Jim is
hopeful about yeah and let me make two
two funny points so one is
I I think there's going to be Continuum
like the word artificial intelligence
won't actually make any sense
right so so humans collectively like
individuals know stuff but collectively
we know a lot more right and the thing
that's really good is in a diverse
Society with lots of people pursuing
individual interesting
you know ideas worlds like we have a lot
of things and more people more
independents
generates more diversity and and that's
a good thing where you know totalitarian
Society where everybody's told to wear
the same shirt and like it's inherently
boring like the Beast speaking through
the monsters inherently dull
right like but in an intelligent world
where not only can we have more
intelligent things but in some places
go far beyond what most humans are
capable of in pursuit of interesting
variety and you know like I believe the
information and well let's say
intelligence is essentially Unlimited
right like and it the unlimited
intelligence won't be the shiny thing
that tells everybody what to do that's
that's that's sort of the opposite of
interesting intelligence interesting
intelligence will be more diverse not
less diverse like that's a that's a good
future
and and your second description that
that seems like a future was working for
and also was fighting for
and that means concrete things today
and also you know it's it's a it's a
good conceptualization like like I I see
the messages my kids are taught you know
don't have children and the world's
going to end we're going to run out of
everything you're a bad person why do
you even exist it's like these messages
are terrible it's the opposite is true
more people would be better we we live
in a world of potential abundance right
it's right in front of us like there's
so much energy available it's it's just
amazing
it's possible to build technology
without you know pollution consequences
that's called externalizing costs like
we know how to we know how to do that
we can have very good clean technology
we can do it would do lots of
interesting things
so if the goal is maximum diversity then
uh
the line between human intelligence
artificial intelligence that we draw it
like you'll see all these kind of really
interesting Partnerships and all kinds
of things and more people doing what
they want which is the world I want to
live in yeah but to me it seems like the
the
question is going to be related to
attention ultimately that is what are
humans attending to at their highest
what is it that humans care for in the
highest you know in some ways you could
say what do humans what are humans
worshiping and like depending on what
humans worship then their actions will
play out in the technology that they're
creating and the increase in power that
they're creating well that's well and if
we're Guided by the negative Vision the
sort of thing that Jim laid out that is
being taught to his children you can
imagine that we're in for a pretty damn
dismal future right human beings are a
cancer on the face of the planet there's
too many of us we have to accept
top-down compelled limits to growth
there's not enough for everybody a bunch
of us have to go because there's too
many people on the planet we have to
raise up the price of energy so that we
don't
what burned the planet up with carbon
dioxide pollution Etc it's a pretty damn
dismal view of of of the potential
that's in front of us
and so you know the world should be
exciting and the future should be
exciting well
we've been sitting here for about 90
minutes banding back and forth both uh
visions of abundance and visions of
apocalypse and
um I mean it's I've been hardened I
would say over the decades talking to
Jim about what he's doing on the
technological front and I think part of
the reason I've been heartened is
because I do think that his vision is
guided primarily by uh desire to help
bring about something approximating life
more abundant and I would rather see
people on the AI front who were Guided
by that Vision working on this
technology but I also think it's useful
to do what you and I have been doing in
this conversation Jonathan and acting in
some senses friendly critics and and
hopefully learning something in the
interim do you have anything you want to
say in conclusion I mean I just think
that the question is linked very
directly to what we've been talking
about now for several years which is the
question of attention the question of
what is the highest attention and I
think the reason why I have more alarm
let's say than Jim is that I've noticed
that in some ways human beings have
become to have come to now let's say
worship their own desires they've come
to worship uh and that even the strange
thing of worshiping their own desires is
that actually led to an anti-human
narrative you know this weird idea it's
almost suicidal desire that humans have
and so I think that seeing all of that
together in the increase of power I I do
worry that the image of the Beast is
closer to what will manifest itself and
I feel like during covid
that sense in me was accelerated tenfold
in noticing to what extent technology
was used especially in Canada how
technology was used to to instigate
something which looked like
authoritarian systems and so I am
worried about it but I think like Jim
honestly although I say that I do
believe that in the end truth wins I do
believe that in the end you know these
things will level themselves out but I I
think that because I see people rushing
towards AI almost you know almost like
Lemmings going off a cliff uh I feel
like it is important to to to sound the
alarm once in a while and say you know
we need to orient our desire before we
go towards these this extreme power so I
think that that's mostly the the thing
that worries me the most and that
preoccupies me the most but I think that
ultimately in the end I do share Jim's
positive vision and I do think that I do
believe the story has a happy ending
it's just
you might have to go through hell before
we get there I hope not
so Jim how about you what have you got
to say in closing a couple years ago a
friend who's you know my age said oh
kids coming out of college they don't
know anything anymore they're lazy and I
thought I work at Tesla I was working at
Tesla at the time and and we hired kids
out of college and they couldn't wait to
make things
they were like it's a Hands-On place
it's a great place and and I've told
people like if if you're not at a place
where you're doing stuff it's growing
it's making things you need to go
somewhere else like and also I think
you're right the mindset of
if people are feeling this is a
productive creative technology that's
really cool they're going to go build
cool stuff and if they think it's a
shitty job and they're just tuning the
algorithm so they can get more clicks
they're going to make they're going to
make something be astly you know beastly
perhaps and and the stories you know our
cultural tradition is super useful both
cautionary and you know
explanatory about something good like
and I think it's up to us to go do
something about this and I know people
are working really hard to make you know
the internet a more open place that
makes your information is distributed to
make sure AI isn't a winner take all
thing like
and these are real things and people
should be talking about them and then
they should be worrying but the the
upside's really high and we've faced
these kind of technological
like this is a big change like the AI is
bigger than the internet like I've said
this publicly like the internet was
pretty big
and you know this is bigger it's it's
true
but the possibilities are amazing
yeah with some sense we could achieve it
yeah it's
and the world is interesting like I
think it'll be a more interesting place
well that's an extraordinarily cynically
optimistic place to end
um I'd like to thank everybody who is
watching and listening and thank you
Jonathan for participating in the
conversation it's much appreciated as
always I'm going to talk to Jim Keller
for another half an hour on the daily
wire plus platform I use that extra half
an hour to usually walk people through
their biography I'm very interested in
how people develop successful careers
and lives and and how their Destiny
unfolded in front of them and so for all
those of you who are watching and
listening who might be interested in
that consider heading over to the Daily
wire plus platform and partaking in that
and otherwise Jonathan we'll see you in
Miami in month and a half to finish up
the Exodus seminar we're going to
release the first
the first half of the Exodus seminar we
recorded Miami on November 25th by the
way so that looks like it's in the can
yeah
yeah yeah
absolutely I'm really excited about it
and just for everyone watching and
listening I brought a group of Scholars
together about two and a half months ago
we spent a week in Miami some of the
smartest people I could gather around me
to walk through the book of Exodus we
only got through halfway because uh
turns out there's more information there
than I had originally considered but it
went exceptionally well and I learned a
lot and exodus means X hotos that means
the way forward and well that's very
much relevant to everyone today as we
strive to find our way forward through
all these complex issues such as the
ones we were talking about today so I
would also encourage people to check
that out when it launches on November
25th I learned more in that seminar than
any seminar I ever took in my life I
would say so it was good to see you
there we'll see in a month and a half
Jim we're going to talked a little bit
more and greatly wear a plus platform
and I'm looking forward to meeting the
rest of the people in your AI oriented
Community tomorrow and learning more
about well what seems to be an
optimistic version of a life more
abundant and to all of you watching and
listening
thank you very much your attention isn't
taken for granted and it's much
appreciated
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com